sur l'immigration c'est un point
fondamental sur l'article 3 du projet
Loi de l'immigration qui permet de
régulariser des clandestins qui
travaillent c'est fondamental pourquoi
parce que d'abord c'est une erreur oui
d'accord mais si le principe et c'est
une erreur politique à ce titre là
d'accorder une prime à la fraude en plus
c'est une erreur empirique parce que
tout ça va créer des appels d'air et
enfin c'est une erreur économique parce
que comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure sur les 2 millions de Français
qui touchent le RSA beaucoup du fait de
l'inflation sont aujourd'hui encouragés
à travailler considérant qu'en fait ils
ont besoin de travailler pour gagner
plus d'argent donc cette triple erreur
fatale pour le gouvernement nous permet
de considérer que c'est l'heure des
choix pour Emmanuel Macron donc si il ne
peut plus permettre il ne peut plus en
tout cas c'est mon souhait il ne peut
plus aujourd'hui être un adepte du
non-soi faire semblant de maîtriser les
flux migratoires et accorder une prime à
la fraude mais tout simplement ne
serait-ce que par respect pour les
immigrer qui ont eu respecté nos valeurs
et respecter nos règles si vous dites
aux Français comme aux étrangers que
vous respectiez les lois que vous les
respectiez pas ça revient au même
comment voulez-vous que tous ceux qui
nous regardent soient encouragés à
respecter les lois oui mais manuel
Macron il dit c'est de l'hypocrisie
parce que sur le terrain même les
députés de droite nous disent qu'ils ont
besoin de ces personnes là c'est de la
manipoliticienne pour essayer de de
fosser le débat oui j'estime pas ça sent
c'est à dire que nous nous avançons avec
des principes mais bien sûr qu'il peut y
avoir au cas par cas en fonction de
situation
une régularisation quelques
régularisations parce que il y a des
histoires de famille parce que il y a
les histoires de très longue date et
puis surtout je vous le rappelle il y a
quand même l'asile politique qui fait
l'honneur à la France et qui permet à
des personnes qui viennent de pays en
danger enfin c'est depuis où ils sont en
danger en danger de de mort d'être
accueilli dignement sur notre territoire
au nom de l'asile politique mais si on
veut pouvoir accueillir dignement on ne
peut pas accueillir tout mais juste
est-ce que vous êtes en position de
force parce que même
ici au sujet
pour cet article 3 mais c'est pas pour
ça qu'on va renoncer à nos convictions
tout est une bataille politique la
politique s'est convaincre la politique
c'est convaincre s'il existe des
principes fondamentaux et que non mais
l'objectif est d'être en majorité n'est
pas d'être en minorité et surtout
d'envoyer un signal un signal très fort
au gouvernement en lui imposant
désormais de faire des choix et
d'arrêter de tirer à eux comme il le
font depuis tant d'années est-ce que
vous êtes en position de l'envoyer ce
signaler nous ferons un peu seul sur ce
que nous ferons tout pour ferme sur nos
positions très au clair sur ce que nous
pensons avec un projet loi
constitutionnel clé en main que nous
attendons de voir repris par le
gouvernement avec une idée très simple
c'est que oui ou non Emmanuel Macron
acceptera-t-il de réformer la
Constitution pour nous redonner le
pouvoir en matière migratoire oui ou non
acceptera-t-il enfin que nous faisions
fit de la jurisprudence extensive des
courses européennes qui ne nous
permettent plus aujourd'hui de maîtriser
nos frontières et de reconduire un email
en descend c'est quand même incroyable
moi je
mets
je
l'Europe manifestement faut la remettre
à l'endroit faut pas la remettre par
terre
[Musique]